marine le pen ce piège et moi on est on
a dit dans son émission qu'on faisait
pas de langue de bois alors excusez-moi
mais leur moelleux depuis le début de
l'émission je suis horrifié les autres
monsieur bédié qui nous promet qu'il va
tenir ses promesses on est très content
un bon il souffre beaucoup monsieur
mélenchon notamment un des critiques qui
sont faites aux politiques et pourtant
qu'est ce que vous les méritez un parce
que qui a contribué à faire croire aux
français que l'intégralité des hommes
politiques étaient malhonnêtes c'est
vous et c'est vous parce que vous parce
que moi parce que mais oui bien sûr
marty mais qui à l'échelle la caisse
claire l'udf